We know we can find it
the face of a rectangle, multiplying
the base on the height.
The face of a rectangle is the height of the base.
In another video we saw that
if we look for a parallelogram face
and we know the length of the base,
and we know its height, then the face
will also be equal to the height base.
It's not that obvious when you look
parallelogram, but in that video
we did some redesign of the person.
We said, "Hey, let's get this one
a small part here. "
We took this small part there
and then we moved it to the right,
and thus see that
provided the base and height are the same
like this rectangle here, I can build
same rectangle by moving this area here.
That's why the face of this parallelogram
is the base of height.
I did not add or remove part of the face, but just shifted a piece
on the left in the right,
to show that the face of this parallelogram
is the same as the face of this rectangle.
This will also be the height base.
So I hope this will convince you,
that the face of the parallelogram is the base at the height,
because now we will use it,
to get a sense of the face of a triangle.
Here are some triangles.
This is a triangle
and we are given the foundation and the height,
and we have to try to think about it
what will be the face of this triangle.
And you can guess it
will depend on the base and the height.
Well, to think about it,
let me copy this triangle.
Let me copy it and then put it here.
And what I will do ...
Now I have two triangles,
so now we will have the face twice,
and I will turn it
here's how,
and then add it to the original person. You will see,
that something very interesting happened.
Now I built a parallelogram,
whose face is twice face
of the original triangle.
Since I have two initial triangles,
here, I saw how I did it,
I copied it and put it here, and then I turned it over,
and I built the parallelogram.
But why is this interesting?
Well the face of the whole parallelogram,
will be the length
on this basis at this height.
You also have the height written
with the reverse side here.
We will have the basis of height.
This will be for the parallel, for the whole -
let me draw a parallelogram here.
This will be the face of the entire parallelogram.
So what will the person be
of the original triangle?
Well we have already seen that face of the parallelogram
is twice the face of the original triangle.
So the original triangle just
will have half the face.
This area will be here
1/2 of the parallelogram face.
1/2 of the base - let me use the same colors.
1/2 of the base height.
And maybe you will say, "Okay, maybe this is for this triangle,
but I want this to happen for more triangles. "
And to help you,
I added another triangle here,
you can see it as a triangular triangle.
This angle here is greater than 90 degrees,
but I will use the same trick.
We have the foundation, we have the height.
Now think so -
if from this point here
throw a ball,
the length at which the ball will move - imagine a stretched rope, -
to get to the ground,
this is the level of the earth,
will be the height.
It is not within the triangle, as we saw last time,
but also the height of the triangle.
If it was a kind of building,
you would say, "So that's the height."
What is the distance from the ground?
First, what will be the face of this?
You can imagine,
that it will be half the height of the base.
Why are we so sure?
Let's do the same trick here.
Let me copy and put this.
I will copy and paste this here.
Oh, it did not work out.
Let me copy it and then put it here.
So now I have two triangles,
but I will turn that back,
so I can build a parallelogram.
I will turn it back and move it here,
I need to turn it a little.
I think you get a basic idea.
Now I built a parallelogram,
who is twice the face
of the original triangle.
And the face
of the entire parallelogram
will be the foundation
at the height of the parallelogram.
But if we only talk about the face of ...
If we talk only about that person
here is the original triangle,
it will be half the face of the parallelogram,
we'll have half of that.
So the face of the original triangle
is half the height of the base.
I hope you have confidence
in this formula that you will encounter in geometry:
the face of a triangle is half the height of the base,
while the face of a rectangle or parallelogram
will be the height base.